what do you think about uh
[ __ ] trump getting banned on all
social media twitter you know a lot of
people ask me that coach
i'm kind of torn on it man well i know
because they're free speech think but
not only the free speech thing but i
feel like it's just going to rile so
many i don't feel like that's not
that that i disagree i don't you can't
let
one or x amount of people listen it's a
company they're making company decisions
remember this right listen if it's a bad
company decision
then f and 70 million people get off
them they'll go out of business
they're making that decision that it's
not gonna be at so
if you're in a capitalistic country
don't let the government tell you have
to go
and let them on either right if you're
really free
the market will determine if it's a good
or bad move
true now if twitter [ __ ] goes down
of course so [ __ ] it loses people and
all this kind of [ __ ]
well twitter made a bad decision right
and then some people will say well
you know would you let just the big tech
companies run the free
no you're not the president if he wants
to get out and make a press [ __ ]
release tomorrow
he's not being [ __ ] silenced right he
can get on
and make a press release he can put out
a press release he can get on national
tv yep he can do anything the [ __ ] he
wants
now they ban every one of those
platforms that new platform whatever
they talked about the one thing
parlor parlor they they're it's in there
i went and looked at it
did you make an account no but i looked
at their
rules they can ban anybody at any time
for any [ __ ] reason
right right well it's right there you
don't like that to begin with
don't get on it but when they do it
don't [ __ ] that they did it
right right for sure they're allowed to
do it i'm not that's not my question
if i know they're allowed to do i think
it's right do i think it's like don't
you
think that
both opinions no matter both sides of
the
of the [ __ ] aisle no matter how
extreme extreme they are should people
should be able to experience them
and make a judgment on if it's right or
wrong all right let me give you so let
me
explain i know what you say the capital
right people see all these
all these crazy [ __ ] going into
the capital with [ __ ] rebel flags and
wearing shirts that say
it wasn't enough what was the thing they
say didn't kill enough jews
these [ __ ] neo-nazis that are in
there whatever people should be able to
see that
and and understand that okay this is
[ __ ] crazy
i need to you should be able to condemn
that or
you know make a decision
about that and nobody's questioned
they're not stopping that
they're stopping one person let me ask
you let me take it to the other level
is it okay for you to go to a movie
theater and scream fire fire fire and
everyone panic since [ __ ] three
people die when they [ __ ] run out of
the place and there's no fire
right no they know that free speech
they're gonna give you all right
is it okay for somebody to recruit
[ __ ] psychopaths that that are not so
outside the mainstream
now we don't let the kkk [ __ ] do that
because it's
you know that's banned now you can't do
that
at what point is
creating anarchy stopped in
in 1937-38 when hitler become
stronger and stronger in power he shut
down
so he was the only one that can do that
if we let one person whether it's a
donald trump anybody whoever is crazy
they did it with alex jones because he'd
do whatever it is
right if we and i get where you're gonna
go
if we let them create more and more
havoc without put stopping him at what
point
do you what happens if he says i i'm on
twitter and i want to mobilize
a half a million people and i want you
to get your arms and we're going to go
to war
is that right no definitely not i mean
that's people are brainwashed
howard stern said people in our
brainwash howard stern
has the biggest audience in the world
he get 15 million listeners a day
they get at avid listeners
how it howard cern knows if he wanted to
he could
mobilize or he he has a a percentage of
that
listen i have a percentage of people i
have a discord
i have a percentage of people i'm sure
that would that are convincible or
whatever you want to call it so now i
have to be responsible
i started getting crazy yeah should i be
shut down or stopped at least for doing
that
right i have to believe at some point
we have to keep civility because if you
say
nobody's allowed to do anything i mean
you you can't shut anybody down they can
do anything they want
right then that guy in that fire that
in that movie theater who goes in there
and causes a riot because he says people
he shot run run run everybody's gonna
die everything tonight everyone
get an old lady gets trampled i'm in
this case in the thing what's going on
now
i think there's a business decisions by
those companies and let the market
bear it let the market bear it
right why don't you shut fox down
right because they're spewing this stuff
about the election
we know it's false come on let's get
everybody out there yeah
and there are people who look they're
gonna be listening saying no [ __ ] no
it's
stolen 60 [ __ ] courts
but federal judges said
there's no [ __ ] fraud the own
administration
that donald trump put in said it was the
most secure election
ever in the history of the in america
did they really yes homeland security
and the election commission
the guy resigned because brunch banner
and he did it
all the money was put in it most secure
election in american history
wow so why are people just inciting
people
to do something stupid that's what that
is
people and people want to be led i know
that i mean people
people don't like you got people i love
that's why i like young people who have
look at the ages of most of those people
most of them are older yeah and i don't
mean they're not your age they're not 25
right right the other they're much older
35 40 45 50.
you know look at the guys that's sitting
on the demands you know they're 50 years
old 45 years old with [ __ ] up lives
probably didn't do anything in their
lives they're not yeah and they want to
be led
they want to be led and i get want to be
live we need leaders
but you need leaders who are going to
push us in the right direction
if that makes sense yeah i mean and so
as far as
i do understand at what point let's
listen the market will bear it out right
because
if it's bad decisions and nobody goes on
it because what you're saying
are you gonna go on twitter i don't know
if you do go twitter yeah i'm still
gonna go on twitter
okay so i guess it's not [ __ ] it's
nothing so bad that you're not done on
twitter right
so they they made that calculation
twitter trust me if twitter thought it
was gonna lose a hundred million people
and they're gonna lose all this revenue
what is not [ __ ] taking you down
right but they made a decision or they
made a decision that was so bad we don't
care about the money
and we're gonna lose it but not only did
twitter do it
facebook did it instagram youtube
listen you and i know some we're on
youtube
there's monetization you know this
if i do something and i've been not i've
i've been demonetized have you been
denial monetized
on specific videos yeah well
when you look for [ __ ] reasons
whatever when you look at it do you
alter your thing
it sometimes it does alter the way you i
do it yeah i look at my twitter and we
put up a video we put up a video early
and we look at the rules yeah and we
skirted them didn't skirt them whatever
we did
and we go back and change it because
we're gonna follow the [ __ ] rule
because
i want to be monetized right right so
they put the rules out i either follow
them or guess what
larry don't get [ __ ] monetized right
and i can't knock that that's the rule
do i wish it wouldn't i mean yes do i
think i'm but then when you look at it
and you look deeper on their end
sometimes it's overboards at least i
believe but
for somebody else it's not you know a
lot of times with content
uh like movie reviews if you make them
your own review
but it that that then you can monetize
but
i had a person russian
take my [ __ ] videos and totally
[ __ ] change the
not do a thing [ __ ] just put my voice
in it and was making money or tried to
make money
really and youtube shut them down thank
you
yeah they protected my [ __ ] thing
by shutting them down and if you look at
youtube most things they shut down is
they're trying to protect somebody
else's content or something else
right right so how do you knock that
that's a business decision yeah
for sure and we you and i as influencers
what do we do we watch what we're doing
we alter it
we still want to have conversations like
we're having or whatever we're doing
but we understand there is a boundary of
some sort because if there's no boundary
dan what are we going to [ __ ] do
yeah there has to be a boundary i agree
i totally agree with that there also has
to be more conversations about things
too people just like to make these
bold statements whether no matter how
untrue they are
and people do get brainwashed by them
and they just they don't think there's
no thinking involved they just like to
repeat [ __ ] that they see or they
hear well i don't know if it's that but
here's the problem
at what point do you believe something
in other words
if you're sitting in front of me and i
[ __ ] show you a
video of a guy
shooting the [ __ ] guy and it's not
altered right
do you believe it maybe
or do you say not my guy he [ __ ] no
that's all
you had professionals you had this doing
it you're doing it
at what point i mean that's the weird
thing right because people already
believe
it doesn't matter you can't change their
business they change their mind they
have
friends of mine they filter it backwards
whatever they see out there
they bring it in and they it either
reinforces what they already believe
or if it doesn't reinforce what they
already believe it's it's got to be fake
it's got to be altered
100 right and it's sad because i have
friends of mine
now this incident now changed a lot of
people totally changed a lot of people
i'm talking
staunch [ __ ] trumpers or because you
know
this incident i have a friend of mine i
know for 40 years
older guy said this ruined him ruined
his life ruined everything and he was a
big trump guy
and was the debate of course never hate
each other i never
i never hate anybody but i i very you'll
never watch my videos right i've
don't use the word hate i think it's a
wasted emotion yeah
i think if i hate it it hurts me not the
person the person you hate don't give a
[ __ ]
it's just hurting you right i dislike
things and i won't go to him or whatever
but i don't hate i give a [ __ ] i just
don't hate
and i i think what's happened is this
incident now
has got people opening their eyes
because they're seeing it i mean
they're i mean i don't know how you
could talk your way out of this
i don't know how you can talk your way
out of this but there are people
already saying oh no i love the couple
of murderer oh that was antivirus in
disguise i know i saw that
then they then they find the guys who
were dang they got on my date
they look them up on their social media
for the last six months or whatever
their proud boy
or this or whatever they are so now they
they did that one
so now the narrative has changed well it
is possible that some of the people
there were there to rile it up too right
it's possible that some people were
there it's always a possibility but
listen if you're that
there's also a possibility that hasn't
been mentioned yet but
how do you know there weren't some
russian spies in there and they were
exactly goddamn devices in there totally
i mean george soros paid for all of it
right george soros paid all those people
yeah it's so [ __ ] crazy
how do you [ __ ] come up with this
[ __ ] no you they're changing the
narrative now to
to switch it to the twitter and the uh
you know all uh uh instagram twitter you
what's the other one i care yeah i just
looked it up
instagram parlor parlor yeah and they're
changing it oh now it's a free speech
issue
no it's not that's a [ __ ] free
country to be a free country that
company can do whatever the [ __ ] it
wants
right why is it a free speech tell me
why it is kind of weird though
it is kind of weird because of the age
we're living in
the technologies we're living with
social media it dominates
everybody's lives to where they have
well
somebody sit back and say wait a minute
don't you say most people have more
interaction or communication on their
phones than they do like
we're having right now absolutely so
it's kind of like
we're teetering on this little edge
where
companies like twitter and instagram are
almost like a public utility
no no no no no no no how do you get that
because you can
if there was one that's a monopoly if
there's two maybe a mob
there's 20 there's how many social me
tick-tock now another countries one
right
blow up china's [ __ ] dick doc blew up
and instagram twitter facebook
[ __ ] mess there's a zillion of them
they really are if you start really
getting down to them yeah
and you can go to which one you want so
you're not being totally silent so
you're not being
just because you aren't on the biggest
one right or you went build this
listen i have a uh
audit and i look at it as a tool
obviously to communicate or whatever
right but if it gets shut down it gets
shut down
i go to the next one you know or if i
don't like
what i did to get shut down i change it
as of youtube
if i do something on youtube that's
where my main thing is
right so i'll change it or if it's not
maybe i'll get to a different platform
maybe it is a uh
uh a podcast but everything is sensed in
his
own way so don't think oh this'll never
senses you that's not that's [ __ ]
they all put it in there so they can
censor you right
but it's up to us
i